[Aplausos]
[Música]
se llama trama creativa y le puse ese
nombre porque creo que todas las
experiencias que vamos teniendo en la
vida van formando un tejido y ese tejido
de conocimientos te define quién sos
como persona y cómo haces las cosas yo
soy autodidacta y aprendí todo con unas
revistas que compraba en el barrio del
11 cuando no existían las cosas
importadas y ahí conseguía la popular
fotografía o la american fotografía y
traducía todo con un diccionario porque
quería aprender inglés me volvía loca
copiando todos los tips tal cual como
decía la revista y entonces agarraba las
cajas de con flex y les ponía miel
alrededor y almendras
y le robaba las cremas a mi madre y
armaba todos unos sets y copiaba
exactamente todos los tips tal cual como
decía la revista a nadie le pasó esto
bueno esas fueron mis primeras puntadas
para generar este tejido que sigue y
sigue para siempre
bueno mi primer desafío fue el cuarto
oscuro la verdad es que me pasaba 10
horas por día
se rozaba el porta negativo con una lija
de metal para que me quedara todo un
marco desprolijo gastaba infinidad de
plata en papel fotográfico tenía un
montón de pasos medidores para preparar
los líquidos lo cual hacía que me
convierta en química prácticamente este
y aparte como no tenía estudio corría
todos los muebles de mi casa y con una
tela de pintor gigante porque no había
fondos infinitos y armaba un estudio
solo que la tela era vez y yo quería que
quedara blanca entonces después en la
copia con un pincel de un pelo lo que
hacía era retocar y hacer el fondo
blanco
nivio con lo cual todo el mundo quedaba
como flotando pero bueno no me importaba
porque era blanco y eran y vio que era
lo importante
bueno esto era los recursos que teníamos
en ese momento y con un poco de
creatividad generábamos este todo este
tipo de cosas porque no tenían ni
siquiera teléfono ni internet ni
absolutamente nada así que bueno
como era fanática del rock empecé a
colgarme de los escenarios siempre
estaba colgada de un parlante fueron mis
primeros pasos en fotografía me ponía
unos tapones en los oídos y ahí estaba
yo cazando yo llamo a este trabajo cazar
con z porque estás esperando el momento
exacto en que se produzca el encuadre
perfecto la luz perfecta
la situación donde el músico está dando
té algo y eso define tu fotografía o sea
me pasé diez años haciendo esto y en un
momento la verdad es que si veía un
músico lo pisaba con el auto
directamente porque no aguantaba más
este decidí dejar de cazar para empezar
a crear y bueno ahí ya me había estado
preparando antes con las cremas y con
las cajas y con todo lo que tenía y
armando me una carpeta que empezaba 5
kilos cada uno con lo cual empezaba a
apuntar hacia la moda y la publicidad
bueno la fotografía para mí tiene
muchísimo que ver con la creatividad y
creatividad es una palabra en femenino
creo que las mujeres tenemos una cosa de
mucha sensibilidad
y siempre pienso de alguna manera en
leonardo da vinci que para pintar la
última escena dispuso una mesa vacía en
un convento en el medio de la nada donde
fue metiendo un pan sentándose durante
cinco días con un pan puesto ahí luego
lo corría hacia otro lado
luego ponía una botella de vino por
supuesto que se comió todo y vació el
convento de todas las botellas de vino
que existían este pero pero él estaba en
su cabeza mirando observando y
decidiendo cómo iba a ser una de las
pinturas más maravillosas de la historia
del arte en mi caso todo pasa
visualmente en mi cabeza quizás como
leonardo en su momento observaba yo
llamo a esto mirada introspectiva
bueno
la verdad es que siempre tengo que
llegar a mis trabajos con una idea muy
clara de lo que quiero hacer realmente
no no no no puedo llegar a un trabajo
sin tener esa mirada introspectiva
previa y saber exactamente qué quiero
hacer que quiero mostrar que quiero
comunicar y de qué manera creativa voy a
generar la imagen que después el público
va a poder observar
en este caso
es la locación lo que me inspira porque
tengo que llegar por supuesto que
previamente voy a verla porque nunca
llegó sin saber dónde basar la
fotografía e iluminación voy a utilizar
cuál va a ser el espíritu el cuentito
que yo voy a querer transmitir a través
de esa imagen y la verdad es que bueno
esto lo hice en un albergue transitorio
este que estaban por demoler o sea que
estaba todo las camas hechas
absolutamente todo como si éste
estuviera funcionando pero a la semana
lo iban a tirar abajo bueno vi este
lugar me inspiré y automáticamente vino
la fotografía
bueno en el estudio tengo como todo más
presente ado en el sentido de que sé qué
iluminación voy a utilizar exactamente
estoy en mi casa de alguna manera por
decirlo así este y en el momento también
quiero probar cosas y ver qué pasa en
este caso puse perdón en el anterior en
este caso puse este un filtro amarillo
en el ojo con un snooze que es como un
flash muy puntual o avispero en criollo
este y al que le puse un acetato
amarillo y la verdad es que me encantó y
fue como esta cosa de la creatividad al
instante no funcionó y quedó la foto
bueno
esta foto también es en estudio y tenía
todo super organizado tenía boceto sabía
lo que quería hacer pero bueno cuando vi
esta esta situación con esa con esa ropa
con ese vestuario tan increíble miré a
mi alrededor y vi unas cortinas blancas
las hice descolgar las puse en unos
trípodes las ilumine y quedó esta foto
que es una de mis predilectas y que yo
creo que tiene como misterio a pesar de
ser blanco sobre blanco así que bueno me
encanta
bueno mis tomas son super adrenalínicas
gritos este trato de avivar y de tener
un contacto y un rapport con el
fotografiado es mi grito se escuchan
desde todo el estudio este pero bueno
eso me hizo dar cuenta un poco de dónde
viene la inspiración por ejemplo cuando
estoy caminando y veo de repente un
árbol donde veo un color verde y me da
la idea de la paleta de colores que
quiero utilizar para un catálogo para
una campaña para la foto de un libro
etcétera muchas veces cuando estoy
lavando los platos estoy absolutamente
pensando en la foto que tengo que hacer
no duermo me despierto a las 4 de la
mañana y anotó o por ejemplo cuando me
estoy luchando es otro momento en el que
me vienen las ideas pero las más
importantes me vienen cuando cuento todo
esto
mi equipo de trabajo y tengo una
devolución acerca de lo que yo pensé y
sigo pensando y me voy con una nueva
versión acerca de mi idea creativa
bueno en este caso de la modelo ya
estaba peinada con un peinado
espectacular y a mí no me gustó sentía
que competía terriblemente con con el
vestuario y con un cartón y con cinta
aisladora negra que fuimos forrando este
cartón redondo al que le hicimos un
agujero en el medio entonces bueno la
creatividad fluye y en un instante me
inspiré para hacer este sombrero que no
existía pero que bueno después de una
hora y media de que el peinador
estuviera peinando lamentablemente esto
es lo que me hizo clic y la idea
funcionó
bueno para mí no existen trabajos chicos
o trabajos grandes en este caso decidí
hacer este trabajo porque creía que era
un gran desafío porque creía que la idea
era maravillosa estas son las
secretarias de los creativos
publicitarios más famosos de la
argentina
si vos querés tener una entrevista con
ellos te van a atender así y no vas a
poder tener la entrevista pero hay una
noche que se llama portfolio night donde
los creativos publicitarios reciben a
los que recién empiezan y les dan una
devolución acerca de su trabajo acá es
de toda la producción y me gané uno de
los premios más importantes del mundo
sin haber cobrado un solo peso que es el
ojo de iberoamérica así que bueno es
importante saber que nuestro nombre va
atrás de cada cosa que hacemos y no
importa si es grande o chico sino que
lleve nuestro sello y nuestro nombre
en cambio acá con un presupuesto enorme
y me gané el premio del círculo de
creativos argentinos habiendo ganado
mucha plata y el día de la entrega de
premios que yo no sabía por supuesto que
lo íbamos a ganar les cuento una
anécdota llegó tarde porque había estado
trabajando y sacando fotos en mi estudio
y entonces lo que sucedió es que el
creativo que había ideado esta campaña
que se llama hombres de ole bajo el
brazo es decir ellos hacen todo con el
diario deportivo abajo del brazo
entonces éste me da el premio nos
ganamos el premio de oro plata y bronce
del círculo argentino de creativos y yo
elegí pero yo me dijo bueno esta campaña
es un casi un 100 por ciento imagen así
que este premio es tuyo y yo bueno me
quedé con guau este súper importante
bueno la inspiración muchas veces ahora
en fotografía viene del cine del teatro
de los libros viene de lugares
increíbles de la pintura y en este caso
me inspiré en citizen kane en la
película de orson welles el director de
arte hizo todos los relojes este en
cartón y plástico y el vestuario también
está inspirado en orson welles así que
es muy importante no la copia sino la
inspiración que podemos obtener de cosas
que miramos que sentimos y que vemos
bueno en el caso de los bocetos es como
jugar con figuritas no empezar a ver
todas estas cosas que nos inspiran acá
tenía que presentar 50 bocetos para que
queden sólo las 6 botellitas así que
bueno no sólo jugué a las figuritas como
loca este sino que me volví loca
pensando este hasta que todo sea limpio
e hizo clic y salieron las 6 botellas
bueno no me gustan las cosas presentadas
los filtros creo que el retoque digital
es una herramienta y no el final que te
va a definir una fotografía y en este
caso por ejemplo algunas veces saco
fotos como la del teatro seis meses
antes y después las 1 y ahí es donde
queda una imagen como ésta donde aplicó
con la herramienta del retoque digital y
aplicó la la imagen pero no para
cambiarla sino para crear una nueva
imagen que antes no existía
bueno
yo creo que
nuestros conocimientos nuestras
experiencias cada trabajo van formando
una trama una trama creativa
es como un tejido un tejido que vamos
construyendo y que ese tejido no termina
nunca porque con los próximos trabajos y
las próximas experiencias este tejido se
va a ir aumentando y creo que lo más
importante de esta trama es que
finalmente define un estilo propio que
es lo más importante que hay que
encontrar así que bueno muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]